oh hello hi I'm a friend I'm a friendly
box who loves to cool he's been
practicing for days my mom I see you
[Applause]
oh yeah exactly
[Music]
stupid game
all right should we do another game game
with me yeah no I'm a shank box well
okay how about you direct your anger
towards the ICU camp yeah I'll see to
you
chugging
I don't know if we can be sneaky god I'm
moving as map is huge warehouse okay
yeah where'd he go
pretty good
I'm come again oh he's cornered she has
a gun
he's got a gun regardless I found him
too I also found him box me bro okay
he's apparently really good at this game
I am but I'm I'm really for my last okay
yes maybe got him
target spotted wait I got him
where'd he go I he's hiding he blended
just point it out because you took my
[ __ ] kill me okay are you gonna do
our tactic now you can steal our are
yeah it's a lie
running away from me your [ __ ] box
you mean box box box
oh yeah yeah if I ran away what are you
still shooting the boxes I mean not that
I would know that okay it's gonna get
some sneaky shots on us like the sweet
he is
is that how Swedes work they why do you
you you're dude I didn't
chasing him get that [ __ ] Irish piece
of [ __ ] yeah yeah okay oh look who's
back in that they seem to be pissing on
can't move that over there they're over
there Ken I told you there I went for
the high five I shot you in the face
instead very sure oh that's perfect
that's perfect look good yeah you look
good just stop spinning
I don't either I can only see like two
feet in front of me yeah I can just see
your box hole I mean it's nice and all
but I don't want to say that you guys
sneaking around not really now are you
guys hiding too are we both just hiding
oh I see him
or you can just gonna check every box
Ken like what are you gonna do I see him
yeah just patience and wait for the
right moment
what Oh Oh Jack come here Jack Jack come
here look behind that Holly look behind
that pallet there's a trap box no no
you're stuck so I'm violent when I'm
cornered yeah I'm still here forever and
ever
yeah they were all looking at me and my
sad situation I got this change teammate
nobody wants to carry a Felix come on
strategy what oh yeah
no now what he did was he was a total
douchebag the entire time and while I
was distracting and catching all the
bullets he snuck up from behind and
killed everybody so got it you distract
catch all the bullets yeah this looks
different was that a battle cry
oh jeez did it that just sounds
intimidating which is wait here it'll be
a low scoring round okay I'm helping oh
yeah
[Music]
ya never find us
well the finest if you're spinning
around like a top but I need to see but
you're too bad I'll see this way you see
that way okay okay I don't know which
you do okay I mean I don't
doesn't help us at all do you or don't
you oh I can't everyone's lying this is
the same place I killed you before you
should have learned I recognized please
I'm gonna get that vantage point again
maybe I could exactly no they don't let
me go to that same spot - it's the same
place I killed you before dad dead dead
he's healing I know that
okay yeah yeah me too but look at corner
box there was two of them that's why it
was weird it was hold on this for some
reason this area is the death area okay
okay I don't know where you're looking
but I'm looking this I'm looking around
I'll watch our six if you can't find us
we win oh yeah good point
it's a good strategy shut up I'm not
moving for [ __ ] oh I think I think they
might be
tactic wait when nine five minutes oh
that was good high five top of the
morning to you papi I was doing the
knife fight you pulled out a gun looks
like we're gonna win all
anticlimactically
[Music]
the room is called joined this Felix and
the password is idiot
wrong pal wait what was the password how
dare you
I'm gonna patchy helicopter yeah I am an
Apache either cop there that babe this
is really it's really coming through
like really getting popular here lately
I don't know what the deal that is you
have I think everyone else is ignoring
the objective Ken oh damn get my bubble
you brought a box a box you've got a box
- my box opener fight I swipe in at the
last minute ha ha ha
I was like maybe I should wait a little
bit in case someone works Pat formation
of a [ __ ]
alright ok I won't do it I want you damn
it
no I just realized there's no sense oh I
get it
ah well [ __ ] it then I believe I got
there oh come on turns into a bunch of
noises just put like some sexy faces on
oh I see hello I see
[Music]
[Applause]
shoot him damn it when they say my
mother point you have too much health
that's not right
[Music]
you died the most
oh my god
is a motorboating holy [ __ ] it's a pony